first try
second try
third try for trial is good
what's good first we feasts your boy Jay
Park AMG High music more love more
laughter more Vision one social and
these are my favorite snacks let's get
it
[Music]
so the first snack Oreos these are the
ones we got in Korea but obviously since
I'm from Seattle I was born in the
states I was you know used to the
American ones but we would do when I was
younger
is we would get a glass of milk and then
we you know
drop two Oreos or three Oreos in there
and we just crush it with a spoon and
then just you know eat that like ice
cream or like a milkshake but now that
I'm older I don't really eat Oreos but
still
every once in a while I enjoy it still
good
oh
so these are Pop-Tarts
s'more flavor I always used to like like
chocolate or caramel as a kid more than
fruit flavors before I go to school my
mom would be too busy to make breakfast
sometimes just pop a couple of these bad
boys in the toaster
I actually haven't seen one of these in
years so it's it's kind of nostalgic to
see a Pop-Tart here in Seoul Korea we'll
see if it tastes the same as when I was
younger
I think it's a little less sweet the
good people here they toasted ones ready
for me
yeah
since it's a s'more you have to toast it
because then it makes the marshmallow
like creamy right it makes me want to go
to school
oh
getting Sugar Rush
what these are
is what they call it in Korean is sweet
red bean pastry there's also this thing
called it's very similar but it's just
in the shape of goldfish but we didn't
have that in Seattle so you know at the
bakery the Asian Bakery my parents would
always pick this up and give it to me I
remember eating this a lot when I was
younger as well you know it's just uh
flowers
probably egg butter sugar you know I'm
not a baker but I'm just guessing and
then just a red bean I don't know if
it's good for you or not probably not
this would go good with milk too
[Applause]
this is that [__] right here Sour Patch
Kids Watermelon flavor
as you can see like right about my
energy and my facial expression like how
I feel about these snacks I feel happy
right now
I was busy today so you know I was kind
of like out of energy but
it's good when I first moved to Korea
every time I went back to the states or
someone would come visit me I'd ask them
to pick up some Sour Patch Kids or I'd
go there and I'd buy like a bunch and I
come back and I give it to like the
homies and stuff in Korea and they'd all
love it it's that [__] stop cash kids
watermelons
oh
so chocolate chips chocolate chips so
when I was younger I would eat a lot of
cereal I eat a lot of cereal I love
cereal I love Lucky Charms Cheerios
Captain Crunch so when I came to Korea
my love for cereal did not die in the
states they have like 100 different
types of cereals from 100 different type
of companies but here they only have
like
three or four types of cereals and one
of them is
you know chocolate chips and you see a
reoccurring theme I guess I like
chocolate I'd actually eat this like
every day I thought cereal was healthy
for you and I thought milk was healthy
for you so what I'd actually just eat a
bowl of cereal a day and that's it my OG
fans my original fans like I they know
that I ate this a lot because I remember
back in the day when I had like a six
pack they're like yo how you how do you
get a six-pack like how you how do you
get abs and I'll just like I eat
chocolate chicks so all the OG fans know
what this is so chocolate chips
chocolate chips is what you call it
oh
damn
about to tear up
[Music]
I haven't seen one of these in I think
almost like 20 years 15 years or
something like that I didn't know if
they still exist when I was younger in
elementary school our mom would pack us
a lunch and so at that time the fat was
this thing called Lunchables right it
was like Cracker cheese ham and then my
mom would put one of these in there and
like a Capri Sun and then send us to
school I used to eat so many of these
thank you for Roll-Ups for the good
memories when I was younger but
I can't fault with you right now 36 year
old me does not [__] with food olives
I'm sorry
oh
this is that [__] too oh my Lord
yes Hostess they had all the apple pies
and twinkies and Ding Dongs and stuff
like that back in my day came wrapped in
foil we put it in the refrigerator so
I'd come home and then take one of these
bad boys out and and eat it with some
milk
and you yeah you see like right away
from like my reaction like it triggers
something in your mind like it gives you
this nostalgic good memories
oh no what is this marshmallow
it looks different
ah it's I don't know
I think it's good but it's different it
tastes too sugary it doesn't taste
creamy when I saw it it gave me a
nostalgic good feeling but now that I
eat it
it's kind of disappointing
like my childhood
this is what you call in Korea
put that in a little captions
I'm a little bit mad
[Music]
yeah everybody thanks for watching those
are my favorite snacks one sold you my
liquor brand coming to a place near you
in the states watch out for that my new
single yesterday is out right now album
tour coming soon hey
and I need to get our hot ones I need to
meet the goat shot Evans Sean Evans get
me on hot ones man Jay Park let's get
this
[Music]